The elements of style won't just ruin
your writing, it'll ruin your life. I've
seen way too many writers lose
opportunities and confidence by rigidly
following the writing rules in style
books like Strunken Whites. Because if
you're hiding behind writing rules, then
you'll never find your voice. So, in
this video, I'm going to show you
exactly how to move beyond these harmful
writing rules to four principles that'll
help you discover the authentic voice
inside you. You know, the one that
builds audiences, influence, and genuine
connection with your readers. Oh, and by
the way, I'm William. I spent 10 years
as an English professor in South Korea,
and now I help writers sharpen their
ideas and reach serious readers. So, if
that sounds like you, then be sure to
grab my free newsletter, Writer Science.
Link is down below the like button. To
be clear, I'm not knocking all the style
tips in The Elements of Style. Honestly,
when I think of those style tips, I'm
reminded of the way that the Earth is
described in The Hitchhiker's Guide to
the Galaxy. Mostly harmless. Sure, some
of their style advice feels a little
empty. Like, be clear. I mean, who's
going to argue with that? Some of their
writing advice is a little obvious, like
don't explain too much because, yeah,
too much literally means you've already
crossed the line. And some of their
advice, like their famous omit needless
words, is basically useless. I mean, if
beginners knew which words were
needless, they wouldn't need the advice
in the first place. So, sure, laying out
these good intentioned reminders isn't
really going to hurt anyone. Even the
really silly stuff like do not inject
opinion doesn't really cause much
trouble. I mean, have you ever tried
stopping writers from giving their
opinions? It's pretty much impossible.
Plus, sometimes opinions are exactly
what we're looking for. But, like I say,
none of these style tips are cause for
great concern. But here's the rub.
Despite having style right there in the
title, this book isn't actually about
style. It's about grammar. And that's
where the real trouble starts. Because
when it comes to grammar, the writing
advice isn't just questionable, it's
downright harmful. For many
English-speaking writers today, the
Elements of Style is pretty much their
only grammar textbook. And given how
terrible some of their grammar advice
is, that's honestly a tragedy. So, while
the style suggestions might slightly
improve your writing, if you can manage
to make sense of any of them, the
writing rules actually make things
worse. Take their classic writing advice
to use the active voice. Sounds like
pretty good advice, right? I mean, who
doesn't want their writing to be active
and vigorous? But let's pause for a
second because there's something weird
about their argument here. To back up
this advice, Strunk and White give us
two example sentences. There's the
active one, I will always remember my
first trip to Boston, and the passive
one, my first visit to Boston will
always be remembered by me. And for
sure, the passive version sounds
awkward, but here's the real question.
Is it awkward because it's passive? Or
is it awkward because they've
deliberately chosen an unnatural
example? Think about it this way.
Imagine you're at a restaurant and
you've just paid the bill. If you turn
to your friend and say, "The bill was
paid by me." That sounds pretty weird.
Not because it's passive, but because
you're placing yourself at the end of
the sentence. Now, the end of the
sentence is known as the stress
position. And more on that in just a
second. But for now, just notice that
writing the sentence in this way gives
yourself a special kind of emphasis. And
that's awkward because you're already
part of the conversation. You're sitting
there in the restaurant. But now, what
if you order at a restaurant, but the
person ahead of you has done one of
those pay it forward things? So, the
cashier turns to you and says, "Oh, the
bill was paid for by the last customer."
Suddenly, the passive voice sounds
perfectly natural, even elegant. Do you
see what's going on here? Strunk and
white are stacking the deck. They're
choosing awkward examples on purpose to
make passive sentences look weak and
awkward. But the passive voice itself
isn't inherently bad. It's all about how
and when you use it. So, if the passive
voice isn't always evil as Strunk and
White would like you to believe, then
the question is when should you use it?
And for that, there are basically five
situations in which you should use the
passive voice. First, you should use the
passive voice or the passive voice
should be used by you when you want the
sentence to focus on the thing that God
acted upon. The subject position is like
a spotlight. So, if you want to bring
the reader's attention to the thing that
receives the action of the verb, use the
passive voice. Second, use the passive
voice when the actor just doesn't
matter. For example, the young couple
were married on a warm summer's day. The
action of the verb marry was performed
by some authority like a judge or a
priest, but the actor doesn't really
matter. The sentence is more interested
in the young couple and the warm summer
stay. So, the passive voice is perfect
here. Third, the passive voice is
perfect for when the actor is unknown.
In the sentence, "My wallet was stolen."
Well, we don't know who stole the
wallet. If you follow and white's
writing rules, then you'd have to use an
empty subject like, "Someone stole my
wallet." But the passive voice allows
you to leave the unknown actor out of
the sentence entirely. For this reason,
politicians love the passive voice
because it allows them to talk about
mistakes without explicitly saying who
is responsible for those mistakes. There
may be a situation here in which a
serious mistake was made. Clearly,
mistakes were made. There were mistakes
made. Fourth, think about this. At award
shows, why do you think they always say
something like, "And the award goes to
Al Puccini and not Al Puccini won the
award." As you might have guessed,
there's a certain emphasis that comes at
the end of the sentence, which is why
it's known as the stress position. And
the passive voice is great for whenever
you want to put an important word in
that stress position at the very end of
the sentence. And finally, sometimes the
passive voice simply sounds better.
Imagine saying writing rules are meant
to be broken. That's the passive voice.
And it sounds way better than the
awkward active version. Someone means
for you to break writing rules. If you,
the writer, decide that the focus should
be on the action or the recipient rather
than the doer of the verb, then the
passive voice can actually be a great
writing tool. And that's the key to
great writing, understanding it not as a
list of rules, but a set of tools.
Unfortunately, Strunk and White have
influenced generations of bad writers
and grammar Nazis. I mean, have you ever
been scolded by a teacher or even by
Microsoft Words grammar checker for
using the passive voice? You know, those
red circles and squiggly green lines
telling you that your writing is weak.
Well, you can thank Strunk and White for
that one. But the truth is, although
these writing mavens warned writers to
never use the passive voice, they didn't
even know what they were talking about.
Nevertheless, thanks to the success of
their book, The Elements of Style, this
misguided advice has been followed
dogmatically by English teachers and
uninformed writers. And the worst part
is that style advice has now been baked
into grammar checkers and AI writing
tools. Let me show you what I mean. In
the section where White advised writers
to use the active voice, they give four
examples of passive sentences. But guess
what? Only one of them is actually
passive. See if you can spot it. At
dawn, the crowing of a rooster could be
heard. There were a great number of dead
leaves lying on the ground. It was not
long before she was sorry that she had
said what she had. The reason that he
left college was that his health became
impaired. So, did you spot the passive
voice? Let me show you. It was actually
the first one. This one is really
passive, but the other three examples
are not the passive voice. Number two is
not the passive. Here we just have a
descriptive sentence. Number three,
that's not passive. It's just a
straightforward past tense sentence. And
number four seems passive because of
impaired, but it's actually an adjective
here. Notice how we can't say a new
addition became issued by the publishers
because became is not a transitive verb,
so it doesn't go into the passive voice.
All right, grammar lesson over. Why does
any of this matter? It's because
misunderstanding the passive voice leads
to unnecessary editing, confusion, and
weaker writing decisions. You might end
up changing a perfectly good sentence
just because some grammar checker
mistakenly corrected it. And if you're
one of these people who actually uses AI
in your writing, then you're going to be
making these mistakes all over the place
because AI cannot think. It can't make
these writing decisions. So, here's the
good news. Identifying the passive voice
is a lot simpler than you think. Just
remember these two easy guidelines. At
the level of grammar, the passive voice
uses the verb to be plus the past
participle. So you get was eaten, were
built, is chosen. And at the level of
meaning, passive sentences put the
receiver of the action first, often
omitting the doer or placing it after
the verb in one of these prepositional
buy phrases, such as the like button was
smashed by you. Why is this important?
Well, knowing this difference empowers
you to make your own decisions about
writing and to ignore the writing rules
from ill-lettered purveyors of writing
misinformation like Strunken White. Next
time you're trying to make your writing
more active, pause and ask yourself, am
I really changing the passive voice
here, or is it just another false alarm?
But I've got to say, after years of
begging writers to stop following the
writing rules in this book, I have found
the biggest objection is that the
authors of the book Strunk and White are
themselves good writers. So it's like,
who are you to say these writing rules
aren't any good? Look at Eie White. He
published Charlotte's Web. And yes, I'd
have to agree. Eie White is a fantastic
writer. But the reason he's a good
writer is because he doesn't even follow
his own writing advice. Seriously, no
sooner do the authors give us a writing
rule than they break it. Not over there
in Charlotte's Web, but right here in
their own writing advice book. In the
section on clarity, they lay out rules
like put statements in positive form and
write with nouns and verbs, not
adjectives and adverbs. Yet immediately
after stating these rules, they write
sentences like this. The adjective
hasn't been built that can pull a weak
or inaccurate noun out of a tight place.
This sentence breaks not one, not two,
but four of their own writing rules.
It's negative rather than positive.
Hasn't been built. It's passive rather
than active. It's overloaded with
adjectives, weak, inaccurate, tight, and
it separates related words, violating
their own rule of keeping related words
together. But this isn't a one-time
blunder. They do it again and again.
just a few pages later. The subject of a
sentence and the principal verb, this is
how I think they sound. Just bear with
me here. But the subject of a sentence
and the principal verb should not as a
rule be separated by a phrase or a
clause that can be transferred to the
beginning. Huh? Again, they break
multiple rules simultaneously. We've got
negative form, passive voice, adjective
usage, and separated phrases. Do you see
what I'm saying here? These are not
isolated gotcha grammar slips. These are
symptoms of a deeper issue. The authors
of this book did not understand the
grammar and writing that they're trying
to teach. They know the terminology.
They've got all the slang words like
subject, verb, phrase, but they lack the
skill to consistently apply these
concepts to their own writing. There are
no secrets in the elements of style that
will improve your own writing. A better
bet is to find examples of writing that
you like and practice writing it out. In
the field of copywriting, this is known
as copy work, where you take an
effective sales letter and you practice
copying it out word for word until you
understand its structure and rhythm. But
you can do this for just about any genre
of writing. Pick an example of writing
that you think is exceptional. Try to
commit it to memory and then practice
out writing it as much as possible from
memory. If you sit there with the book
open, I don't think you get as much of
an effect as if you're working from your
own memory. Once you start to recognize
the mistakes and contradictions in
writing guides, like the elements of
style, then your own writing can
immediately become stronger and clearer.
Take the infamous rule against split
infinitives, placing an adverb between
to and a verb, like the famous to boldly
go where no man has gone before. If you
ask white, writers should avoid
splitting infinitives unless the goal is
specifically to emphasize the adverb.
But this rule is not just outdated. It
doesn't make any sense. It's wrong. All
right, maybe this is getting a little
bit unfair. I mean, these guys are like
long since dead, and I'm just whailing
on them here.
He's already dead. But we've got to
address this one because it's it's
seriously wrong. Now, to be fair, Strunk
himself never mentioned split
infinitives. It was EB White who later
introduced this unnecessary writing
rule, despite admitting elsewhere that
split infinitives can actually enhance
clarity. Consider this sentence. The
president's statements tend to
completely polarize the public. Strunk
and white would claim that the split
infinitive to completely polarize
emphasizes the adverb. But the opposite
is true. If your goal is to highlight
just how total that polarization is,
then you would want to place the adverb
at the end of the sentence in the stress
position. The president's statements
tend to polarize the public completely.
Why does the second version feel
stronger? Because as Strunk and White
correctly point out elsewhere, words
placed at the end of the sentence
received the greater emphasis. That's
the stress position at work. So once
again, they couldn't even follow their
own writing advice when condemning split
infinitives. The problem with the
writing advice in this book isn't the
split infinitives. It's
misunderstanding where sentence emphasis
truly belongs. Splitting infinitives is
often completely natural and clear. And
here's exactly how you can apply it in
your own writing. If you want to tie an
adverb closely to the verb, then it's
totally fine to split the infinitive.
But if you really want to highlight an
adverb or a key idea, then place it at
the end of your sentence in the stress
position. Shrunken White were unable to
consistently follow their own writing
advice, but now you know better. So, by
all means, if you want to be over
opinionated and underinformed, then go
ahead, enjoy Strunken White. But if
you're tired of the over opinionated and
ill-lettered grammar Nazis like Strunken
White laying down a bunch of trivial,
don't do this writing rules, then you
need to watch this video next because
it's going to teach you how to cut
through the rules to get a deeper
understanding of how writing works using
a hilarious video from College Humor.
So, be sure to go check it out.